[Musik]
in dieser perfekten blogger kulisse in
bonita springs florida lebt gemeldet
neben modefotos post sieht vor allem
politischer videos und verteidigt
präsident schon im netz nennt sie sich
the blond politischen die meisten
follower hat sie auf einer neuen
plattform der politischen rechten weg
news können hier ohne einschränkung
verbreitet werden
diese story wird einige follower
abschrecken
es geht immer um eine story die mich
anspricht
besonders themen wie ungerechtigkeit und
fairness
die story heute dreht sich so ein
bisschen um zensur wie medien und große
social media konzerne uns vorschreiben
wollen was wir zu denken haben sie mein
twitter facebook und co
während der us-wahl sperrten und
markierten die unternehmen post in denen
falschinformationen verbreitet wurde es
ist nicht das erste mal dass tech
unternehmen eine rolle in den
nachrichten gespielt haben
auch camille bekam eine warnung weil
ihre story die regeln der plattformen
verletzt hatte sie ist traum fan und
glaubt seine erzählung die wahl wurde
gestohlen
wenn du bei google stoppt das stehlen
eingibst wirst du als
verschwörungstheoretiker rinn bezeichnet
beifahrer passierte das nicht ihre
stories über betrug und zensur sind hier
erfolgreich facebook und twitter
vergleicht sie mit adolf hitler
seit der us wahl hat paula einen schub
bekommen
spätestens nachdem führende medien joe
biden zum wahlsieger erklärten alles
betrug meinen job fans partner ist die
einzige plattform die freie
meinungsäußerung schützt hanna ist voll
von verschwörungen und hass sagen
experten
die online rassismus bekämpfen ich denke
kader könnte gefährlich werden wenn
daraus eine eigene sich selbst
überlassene webseite wird die nur noch
von extremisten gespielt wird das ist
durchaus möglich camions post finden bei
kahla den meisten zuspruch
die folgen 130.000 menschen auch ihrem
vater dem konservativen autor david hat
sie eine seite eingerichtet
seit jahrzehnten ist er mit der us
politik verbandelt war einst ein berater
von präsident bush senior
nun steht er hinter trump hat sogar ein
buch über ihn geschrieben hat weiß laut
und wütend sein beach amt macht bekannt
ich kenne viele menschen über die
camille in ihren videos spricht beim
namen die nicht glücklich damit sein
werden was sie sagt oder tut aber auf
der anderen seite weiß ich was der
schlüssel zum erfolg ist auch politisch
nämlich kontroverser früher kommentierte
doug bei fox news heute bei newsmax
konservative sender wie newsmax bekommen
wie auch paula seit der us-wahl immer
mehr fans bei twitter und zuschauer im
tv ich habe komplett newsmax und
american news gewechselt und vertraue
darauf dass sie klarmachen dass diese
wahl noch nicht vorbei ist denn das
fox news trumps ehemaliger
lieblingssender hat er in arizona einem
schlüsselstaat als erstes beiden zum
sieger erklärt damit lag er dann
deutlich vortrag für trump fans
ungeheuerlich es wirkt wie eine
parallelwelt in der sie überzeugt sind
hat nicht verloren immer wieder werden
diese proteste auch begleitet von
gewaltbereiten gruppen die den topos
[Musik]
vernetzt und organisiert haben sie sich
meist eine große gefahr von pala sind
gruppen wie die braut boys sie können
sich dort offen vernetzen wo sie von
mainstream plattformen wie twitter und
facebook ihr unterdrückt werden
bei prada haben sie nun ein zuhause
gefunden das ist bedrückt mit dem online
infokrieg wollen trump und seine fans
vor allem auch eines erreichen
an den sieg bei der stichwahl im januar
in georgia
dort entscheidet sich ob drums partei
zumindest die mehrheit im senat behält
er droht dem örtlichen gouverneur der es
gewagt hatte ihn zu kritisieren
neuer gouverneur sollte sich schämen das
ist was sie hier in georgia wollen euch
mundtot machen
sie wollen dass ihr geht aber wir werden
nicht gehen
während ramp seine fans weiter
anstachelt erhalten demokratische
politiker innen in georgia morddrohungen
bei social media wie elena parent bei
einer anhörung in sachen wahlbetrug
verteidigte sie den beiden sieg es ist
eindeutig dass die menschen in georgia
joe biden als nächsten us-präsidenten
gewählt haben und diese haltlosen
nebenschauplätze gefährden sowohl die
menschen in georgia als auch die
gewählten politiker in
auf der einen seite behaupten die tram
fans sie dürften nicht freisprechen
auf der anderen seite tun sich hier
genau das sagen was sie wollen
beiden wird niemals unser präsident sein
er soll zurück in seinen keller gehen er
ist weg vom fenster
wir akzeptieren keine prompt niederlage
es gab zu viel betrug in ihrer welt hat
trump gewonnen
auf der straße und online soll dass
jeder hören
das sind eben nicht immer menschen die
sich nur für freie rede starken sie
wollen social media übernehmen und so
nutzen dass wir in eine beunruhigende
autoritäre richtung gelenkt werden
die us wahl ist nun fünf wochen her und
im januar wird joe biden vereidigt
doch diese realität scheint bei vielen
fans noch nicht angekommen zu sein
sie kämpfen weiter mit demonstrationen
hass im netz
und manchmal einfach nur mit einem
schönen foto
[Applaus]